hello and welcome to the new order of
your source for everything anime and
manga and we are back today to talk
about clovers preferably black ones as
we review the royal knights arc which i
suppose is the black clover take on the
standard shonen tournament arc which was
quite enjoyable i'm always a sucker for
that kind of format yes i am and there
was plenty to like about it but of
course some minor stuff that made me go
a bit
hmm but before we do the thing with the
talking if you're enjoying these black
clover dives and i would highly
encourage you to like this video and
subscribe to the channel numbers are
telling me that you guys seem to be
quite enjoying these videos so do keep
it up because i refuse to read comments
because i know that someone
somewhere is going to spoil something i
know you're out there
let's get into it though the royal
nightstark is probably the most
simplistic story that we've encountered
thus far in black clover and it takes
place almost exclusively in one location
with one core mission statement that we
don't really diverge from that doesn't
say it's a bad thing i'm just very used
to the sudden twists of black clover now
however tournaments are a great shonen
staple almost every battle manga will
feature one in some form of the course
of its publication and it's because
they're kind of a super format
the standard belief is that tournament
arcs get used as an excuse to amp up
action as well as artificially inflate
drama under this kind of construct and
yes that can be true however what's
always struck me as great about
tournament arcs is how they can be used
to showcase character development and
interactions so for example in the royal
nightstark we get to see a whole ton of
bizarre action-based interactions such
as asta vs magna which you would just
never have the opportunity to see
anywhere else because coming up with a
reason for them to fight would be rather
convoluted and tabata does spice things
up quite nicely by mixing up our magic
knight squad so it's not like our
standard black bulls versus golden dawn
which it very easily could have been
instead we get this nice pick and mix a
bit of noel here a bit of you know there
cap it off for the mushroom and mmm
delicious but it results in some really
captivating teams and a lot of fun
dynamics my favorite of which is asta's
team which we will get into
but firstly i do have to say that as
much as i do love tournament arcs i was
kind of disappointed by the setup for
this one mostly because to be perfectly
frank i still don't understand what
we're doing
why we're doing it and even how we're
doing it like i do get that the general
point is to form some sort of super
squad to attack the eye of the midnight
sun which
is cool but why are we doing it with
these specific people we have a total of
48 candidates which are a mixture of
ranks but dominated by rookies with a
couple of vice captains and even one
captain
so how did we make the decision to you
know
get here was this an invitation only
tournament or was it open to anyone who
wanted to be here if so why aren't there
tons of other magic knights vying for
this
allegedly prestigious position
especially the more noble ones which is
like
all of them or why is it this specific
group of the black bulls and not
everyone else you know where's vanessa
go shami charmy well
charmy is here but not to participate
but do you know what i mean and i guess
i could accept the reasoning that the
only people here are the ones with
something to prove but at the same time
that's kind of at odds with the purpose
of the selection exam itself which is to
find the best of the best of the magic
knights in order to pit them against the
greatest threat
currently facing the clover kingdom so
on the one hand we have this profoundly
important purpose and outcome but the
process to get there is almost entirely
frivolous because we have this
completely arbitrary group of people
mostly populated by hothead rookies
competing for this
monumentally important task oh and i
should mention that mr wizard king
states that part of the reason for the
exam was to weed out the unconscious
betrayal which does present itself
within language
language but even then unless you're
going to put the entirety of the magic
knight forces in this situation you're
basically just crossing your fingers and
hoping that the betrayer is one of these
arbitrary people it's just a less than
solid setup but you know what
it's it's also kind of fine i can get
over the structure and the motivations
and everything else because tabitha's
true skill shines in characters and
there is a lot to work with here
starting with someone who almost
automatically became a favorite of mine
being zora i love his design i love his
magic his backstory is appropriately
tragic and everything about him comes
together to form this very compelling
presence and it was very interesting
because at first i thought he was going
to be this perfect philosophical counter
to astor you know our protagonist who
loves teamwork and then hears zoro who
insists on working alone but in the end
the two of them turned out to have an
extraordinarily similar value system
especially when it comes to their ideals
of the magic knights or i suppose in
zora's case his father's ideal of what
the magic knights were which is kind of
mirrored by astor's words in their final
round
i also love the idea that despite his
very villainous design and dickish
nature
zora didn't actually turn out to be our
main antagonist of the aqua really an
antagonist at all he was a fun red
herring in that regard and he turned
into a solid ally quite quickly with he
and astor even giving each other cute
little compliments during their second
match and in the end they were actually
a pretty great team and i would love to
see zora just flat out join the black
balls he's perfect for them being a
lowly peasant outcast who goes against
the grain but that's really the only way
i could see him actually joining the
magic knights because i don't think
there's any other squad that really
embodies his father's ideals with that
said i do also think it was
just a little bit weird that nobody
recognized the fact that zora was
impersonating another magic knight a
vice captain no less
i mean the wizard king sure he's a
cheeky mofo and he'd let something like
this just happen but did nobody else
know what the vice captain of the purple
orcas looked like it was quite shocking
just how easily zora managed to get away
with his facade moving on though also on
team aster we had
mimosa a selection that made me audibly
say quite strongly at first because i
thought that she was just going to be
some sort
of noel replacement who would go on to
spend most of her time doting over astor
and maybe do something useful
on one occasion but that i am happy to
say was not at all the case mimosa was
actually
kind of a boss in this arc she even took
the role of leader in the first round
and had some choice words for her
brother when she stated make sure you
win this match because in the next round
astor and i
intend to slaughter you which is the
kind of determined sass that i really
love
plus she also fit in perfectly with the
whole team dynamic on so many different
levels as well she was great for
protecting the crystal she counted
soul's golem and mimosa was even able to
heal astor which is pretty perfect
because his crowning feature tends to be
how heavily injured he becomes in combat
and it made me realize that in many many
ways mimosa is a much more natural
combat partner for astor than noel and i
guess i just want to say
congratulations to tarbeta for taking a
character that i really did not care for
and turning her into mimosa vermillion
speaking of vermilions or familiai
whatever the collective noun is mimosa's
brother kirsch was a surprising favorite
of mine i mean everything about him is
horrible but in the most hilarious of
ways he's not like noel's siblings that
are just kind of sickening kirsch has a
lot of redemptive qualities just when it
comes to pure comedy and a great
selection of one line is for everyday
use
such as my favorite which is silence
filth you're polluting my
heir but in addition to this he's
actually quite helpful as well giving
magna and soul some very well conveyed
advice regarding how to more effectively
use their magic which was a bit of a
surprise for that kind of character and
of course he does have a change of heart
at the end where he discovers that his
definition of beauty is narrow and
lacking meaning that he should be a
nicer character for us to follow in the
future
maybe probably that's how most of them
tend to go but as for the centerpiece of
the arc this was unexpected but it all
spawns from finral
and langris langris and honestly this
was probably the matchup i was least
excited for because by that point in the
tournament the format was dragging just
a little bit but tabitha clearly felt
that as well and decided to switch
things up by having finra lose and
language go
ever so slightly insane causing a very
high stakes conflict against aston and
his team to commence and so it actually
became the only match in this arc that i
was solidly invested in because it had
the weight of finral behind it and in
retrospect it was also a really great
payoff for the layering that tabitar had
been conducting in previous arcs you
know gradually building finral up
through stuff like the underwater temple
then introducing language at the star
festival and now having all of that work
coming to a boiling point here in this
arc which also gave us a very nice
victory for asta in his
newly controllable transform state
because despite the fact that this match
was officially a tie it wasn't really
about winning in the end more about
making sure that langris was defeated
with his oddly
eye of the midnight sun vibes with that
said the greatest moment of the arc by
far belongs to finral when he sent sekke
directly to army sitting on the toilet
through spatial magic that cooked quite
a lot for me i'm still laughing about it
now
but we also had a captain participating
real of the aqua deers also known as the
suckiest squad now after the black bulls
have broken their losing streak and i do
like his concept quite a bit with the
whole misunderstood artist vibes he's
also pretty terrifying given that his
artistic muse is essentially his
opponent and the stronger his opponent
is the greater the desire to create he's
the sort of character i like because he
does possess amazing power but quite
strict limitations on how it can be used
so he's not
in any way overpowered because he does
have to meet that mental criteria i find
that sort of stuff much more satisfying
than someone with phenomenal power who
can access it easily and use it to
perfection that sort of thing kind of
bores me
which you know is sort of what you know
is becoming after asda's tied the final
matchup sees yuno directly take on a
captain and not only that but he does
win fire a technicality it was real's
fault i guess but i was hoping to see
yuna lose here for the first time i
really wanted him to have his astor
moment of hitting a ceiling then being
forced to go away and figuring out how
to penetrate said sealing but instead
yuno is perfect as per usual which i
suppose
is fine because it does counter
balanceaster's wild imperfection
you know gets to where he is through
seemingly no effort at all meanwhile
aston needs to struggle with all of his
might at every step still makes me think
that yuna must have been born a noble
child though because this natural talent
is very comparable to theirs if not
greater
in fact i would say definitely greater
as for noble children i would be remiss
not to mention that noel got to take a
step forward here by soundly defeating
her brother solid silver which is such
a cool name for such a disappointing
existence and my favorite part of this
whole conflict was seeing the split
panel of noel in the present versus noel
and past because it was a great
indicator of showing how much she's
changed and how ready noah was to take
on solid and she did it so you know what
screw you
solid silver and you are the siblings
you better watch your backs as well and
there were moments of other interests
like klaus's brief moment of growth and
the um
the fungus magic user whose name i don't
remember but it was pretty funny overall
though this arc was pretty
straightforward there were a couple of
surprises as well as a banquet of what
is now becoming the signature topper to
micro flashback and just a lot of
character growth all around which is the
reason why i can look past the more
structural issues of the arc and
in fact the series in general if these
characters were even mildly less well
written then i think i would have lost
interest in black clover a bit of a
while ago however i can't help but want
to read about them i want to see each
and every one of them overcome their
various obstacles in life and tabata has
a great method of allowing a scale of
empathy that you normally
wouldn't find with secondary or even
tertiary characters in very badly
written series you can't even find it
with the primary characters so i'm
guessing we'll find out what the actual
results of this
exam thing were and where this bizarre
trip of individuals is going to be taken
during the next dock so yeah i'ma do
that right now but that pretty much does
it for this blind review of the royal
night sock and what do you guys think
please do leave your thoughts in the
comments below or even join my discord
server and if you're keen for some more
black clover content then please to go
and check out some of my other videos or
even subscribe to the channel for
very maybe regular black clover goodness
delivered straight into your youtube
feed but for now this has been the new
world review and i'll see you next time